Digamos que tengo algún tipo de superficie. Esto
que estoy dibujando es la parte superior de un
escritorio, y voy a dibujar un triángulo en esta
superficie, así que tal vez el triángulo se ve
así. No tiene que ser un triángulo rectángulo, no
estoy insinuando que éste sea necesariamente un
triángulo rectángulo, aunque se parece un poco
a uno. Llamémoslo triángulo ABC. Ahora, lo que
voy a hacer es algo interesante, voy a tomar
un cuarto punto P que no está en la superficie
de este escritorio, va a estar justo por encima
del punto B. Así que permíteme dibujar ese punto
que está directamente arriba, y voy a llegar al
punto P. Ahora lo que puedo hacer es construir una
pirámide usando el punto P como la punta de esa
pirámide. Vamos a comenzar a pensar en qué es lo
que sucede si tomo secciones transversales de esta
pirámide. En este caso la longitud del segmento PB
es la altura de esta pirámide. Ahora, si fuéramos
a la mitad de esa altura e hiciéramos una sección
transversal de esta pirámide paralela a la
superficie de nuestro escritorio, ¿cómo se vería
eso? Pues se vería algo así. Quizás estás notando
algo realmente interesante. Si trasladamos ese
triángulo azul directamente sobre la superficie
del escritorio se vería así, y cuando lo ves de
esa manera parece que es una homotecia de nuestro
triángulo original centrado en el punto B. Y de
hecho es una homotecia centrada en el punto B con
un factor de escala de 0.5, y puedes verla justo
aquí, esta longitud justo aquí, disminuyó a la
mitad de la longitud del segmento BC original.
Esta es la mitad de la longitud del segmento AB
original y luego esta es la mitad de la longitud
del segmento AC original. Y podemos hacer esto a
otras alturas a lo largo de esta pirámide. ¿Qué
pasaría si tuviéramos que ir 0.75 del camino entre
P y B? Si tuviéramos que llegar justo aquí para
estar más cerca de nuestro triángulo original,
entonces la sección transversal se vería así.
Ahora, si tuviéramos que trasladar eso a nuestra
superficie original, ¿cómo se vería? Se vería así,
como una homotecia de nuestro triángulo original
centrado en el punto B, pero esta vez con un
factor de escala de 0.75. Y luego, ¿qué pasa si
vamos solamente una cuarta parte del camino entre
el punto P y el punto B? Bueno, entonces verías
algo como esto. Dibujamos la sección transversal
paralela a la superficie original a una cuarta
parte de la altura y se verá así. Si tuvieras
que trasladar esto directamente sobre nuestra
superficie, se vería algo así, y se ve como una
homotecia centrada en el punto B con un factor de
escala de 0.25. Y la razón por la cual todas estas
homotecias se ven como homotecias centradas en
el punto B es porque el punto P está directamente
sobre el punto B. Pero esta es una forma de
conceptualizar homotecias o ver la relación
entre las secciones transversales de una figura
tridimensional -en este caso una pirámide- y cómo
esas secciones transversales se relacionan con la
base de la pirámide. Ahora permíteme hacerte una
pregunta interesante: ¿qué pasaría si tratara
de tomar una sección transversal justo en el
punto P? Bueno, entonces obtendría un punto, no
obtendría un triángulo real, pero podrías verlo
como una homotecia con un factor de escala de 0.
¿Y qué pasaría si tuviera que tomar una sección
transversal en la base? Entonces tendríamos
el triángulo original, el triángulo ABC,
que puedes verlo como una homotecia con un factor
de escala de 1 porque has recorrido todo el camino
hasta la base. Así que espero que esto te ayude
a conceptualizar las secciones transversales de
una figura en tres dimensiones, que son paralelas
a la base, y cómo se relacionan con la homotecia.